hi my name's miles ward
I run Solutions architecture here on
Google cloud but this isn't my first
cloud I made the switch three and a half
years ago from AWS and I've been talking
to a lot of customers and partners that
are in the middle of trying to do the
same thing say they learned the basics
about public cloud from AWS is training
and certification programs but they're
looking at the features of Google cloud
and the sophistication of our technology
and really eager to apply that to their
problems so we thought maybe we should
put together a training course that
leverages that existing expertise your
familiarity with AWS is public cloud and
allows you to apply that to our new
generation technologies maybe you want
to learn more about a system that allows
you to automatically scale from no
connections to a million connections in
under a second or a system that can
process petabytes of logs without ever
having to manage an instance maybe you
want a system that doesn't quite cost so
much or about 60% cheaper on average
maybe you're just tired of complexity
and you want a cloud that is easy easy
easy
this training course is designed just
for you it's about six hours long the
first hour and a half
covers the fundamental differences the
design differences between our cloud and
Amazon's helps you understand and maybe
be able to better guess how our system
helps you build the tools you're trying
to build and then four and a half hours
of fast-paced deep hands-on labs that
give you firsthand experience with our
infrastructures of service systems but
also our platform as-a-service databases
of service both relational and
non-relational functions as a service
all manner of tools that make this such
a rich suite we think that this course
enables you not only to take on your
first experiments with Google Cloud but
prepares you in the right way for future
endeavors and exploration I'm excited
about this course I just took it I
thought it was really informational and
I think you'll have a great time with it
thank you so much